when the all-time greats and not just a
coach but a person best man at mooches
wedding Tom Izzo here in the Rajasa Joe
how are you Cody the same week as
Charles that's a good yeah well I
all-time greats but I'm good which I'm
good I want to be fair and balanced
coach you know I gotta get I gotta get
the Spartan point of view here for this
big game no I wanted to doll you up and
see how you're doing certainly with the
Wolverines uh set to potentially lay
down lay down the law here this is going
to be a fun one I think and with fun
ones I don't know if this will be a fun
one so well we'll see and make it fun
you know we've kind of all the pressures
on you not as much as on us not sure
either way I think we're ready to play
we played really well and plays well
fourth quarter but this week I think
we'll try to total four quarters
together what's your relationship with
Dantonio like Tom yeah it's really good
you know me and football guys I like
them more than that you know but I had a
good relationship with ball out of the
relationship
Lloyd Carr you know Lloyd card and mooch
and I went to northern Michigan you know
he's a little older than Osmond we did
we did graduate from the same high
institution and northern Michigan I'm
sorry I you know mooch calls it the
northern Michigan you know that right he
calls it so but I guess you know do you
and Dantonio have conversations or you
know just sit back because you know
obviously you guys are face front
individuals for your university coach we
have conversation we live about a block
from each other and in fact we got in
about 3:00 3:30 last night rich and I'm
on the road to go to Canada do a little
recruiting and I talked to him this
morning before I left so yeah
we do in fact normally I go down for the
game but we play again on Monday so I
don't think I'll be there in person but
I will I'll schedule practice so I can
watch the entire thing just in case you
and I make another wage you can bet we
will do that but we can we could put a
pin in that you were there you were
there for the for the for the botched
punt for Michigan right you were there
any building that night right no no no
Tom I hit that button went straight to
voicemail I didn't want to answer the
phone I wasn't talking to anybody I
wasn't talking to my wife I wasn't
talking my kids I didn't talk to anybody
after that one so I love this that we're
talking about now gosh now they're
showing video of this on the screen can
we please remove this here this is my
own staff if you will my own crew oh my
gosh so this is interesting so here you
are you do you play in Brooklyn last
night you take on Seton Hall tight game
now you're home you're already in a car
driving to Canada to look at somebody
that's the the life of Michigan State's
Tom Izzo is that what's happening right
now yeah it's it's really a glamorous
life I'm kind of driving over the bridge
right now the Ambassador Bridge if you
can remember back to the oceans around
an arbor I you'll know the Ambassador
Bridge and some driving over it now and
god this is a game at 2:00 or 2:30 and
then go back what off today because we
got back so late so that's why tomorrow
like I can't sneak away like I normally
would I I don't
it's many games over the years like most
of them that's better than you've done
and when's the last time you been back
for once you know what I was the
honorary captain at for a couple years
ago and I asked mooch cuz that Harbaugh
asked me to address the team which is
one of the people I reached out to say
what in the world do I say and how do I
say and he's like speak from the heart
you know speak from the heart and it's
interesting too on that front coach you
know that's that's what you do so well
one of the many things you do so well
I saw what you mentioned this week in
your addressing the media after the
passing of Zachary Winston caches his
brother nicknamed smoothie and you wore
patch in his honor last night what where
do you find
I guess that reserve where do you go to
when obviously that's your your role
beyond the X's and O's bit here
hopefully I don't go out if you can hear
me I can't hear you go for it something
judge didn't leave in the book you know
he's no chapter on that it with comfort
things that I've been involved with rich
and it's a great kid great family and a
lot of people from a lot of different
areas of you know kind of made
statements about it they've all been
good it was just a tough deal and it's
gonna remain a tough deal for a while
I'm sure but we've kind of tried to
rally around it and that's what we're
doing
mm-hmm and and and where do you I mean
do you do you pull the kid I saw it I
mean like what what uh as you said you
know there's no rulebook on it I'm just
wondering where what do you what do you
do part you know I tried to tell them
that I'm gonna be this one I'm gonna
I'll be a good listener if he needs me
to talk once in a while I will but I
said you know as long as you're gonna
play I still got to coach you to and so
it's been pretty good you know that a
lot of dialogue back and forth and you
know the first game which was within 20
hours of when it happened played really
good and everybody told me you know that
he playing adrenaline the first time it
gets harder and he he played pretty good
last night but not as good you know it's
been a tough practice scene and his
families you know thank God his family's
close enough that they've been around
and there's been a lot of time with them
today and this weekend but you know it's
I gotta tell you Richards and yet Who am
I I mean he's got to deal with it his
family's got to deal with it I just got
to be supportive of it
tom izzo here a couple more minutes with
the Michigan State head coaches he's
making his way to Canada to see a game
day after dispatching of the Seton Hall
and then again what do what what do you
look for in your team here it is I'm
again is the long slog where we're not
even at Thanksgiving yet and you want to
get to March you want to cut down a net
in April what is your what is a plan for
a coach in that scenario well you know
we opened with Kentucky in the garden
we played Seton Hall was number 12 we
head to Hawaii next week he happens to
his numbers there it's almost like Marth
hmm we got a long way to go you know we
look yeah I named Josh Langford who
probably I think we're all year starters
so that's been a little we're adjusting
to that and then you know adjusting to
the tragedy so right now where you're
not trying to keep water and yet build
it and yeah I think we're gonna have to
just pick up the phone there would you
would you there Mikey
Chris tell them tell him you know if you
get there you can you pick up there
Chris pick up there if you get them tell
them that uh I can't wait to busy there
can't wait to tell him I can't wait to
send them Michigan pajamas that's what
we should do I should send him like a
big Michigan Snuggie pajama right all
right
right that's Tom Izzo here on the Rich
Eisen show the great head coach of
Michigan State basketball right here on
the show is he busy back on you got him
no no he's talking he's he talking your
ear off over there what's going on over
there Chris trying to figure out if the
coach and I are working on a bet okay so
tell him I said thank you and say hey
for more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR live or download the Rich Eisen
show app